Which way is up to you, the y or z axis?
I mean when you're working on a workstation and your screen is vertical, then I think of it as y up but people
working with pads now you sort of have this case where the z is coming out of
your pad, your tablet, because you're working in this direction.
I would say, negative y Because that's how my old VGA card on my PC worked. For some reason
the Y axis points downwards on them so when you started making the first 3D
effect which was like, you know, the star scroller, you're like flying toward in
a some kind of galaxy with stars. You ended up with, you know, when you
increased Y the points were moving downwards. So I would say - negative y, that's up.
For me, because I'm in a shop all the time, z is always up. And
then that has to do a lot with like CNC machining, you know. If I'm in the shop
it's always the Z, if you're doing 3D printing it's always the Z axis.